on y vient pour la randonnée ou pour la
gastronomie et on tombe sous le charme
de ses anciennes cases de changement
d'air nicher dans la verdure du cirque
de Salazie elle bourre vitorisme
tranquille des nuages qui le recouvre au
fil de la journée mais le bourg se
souvient-il de celui qui lui donna son
nom
pourquoi ça s'appelle albour elle boit
un esclave elle boit elle boit elle goût
son jeu de mots je ne sais pas il y
avait donc un gouverneur
qui donc habité ici à albour
elle bourre tient son nom du gouverneur
anne-chrétien Louis de elle Contre
Amiral qui débarqua à Bourbon le 5 mai
1838 et il resta 3 ans et demi pendant
son administration il fut saisi par le
gouvernement de trois projets visant à
faire le point sur la situation des
esclaves en vue de leur émancipation ces
trois réponses furent rassurantes
était bien traité il n'y fallait rien
changer il eut aussi le privilège de
parrainer de localité el bourre dans le
cirque de Salazie et elle ville
chef-lieu de Nocibé une île de
Madagascar déclarait dépendance de
Bourbon en 1841 mais le Helbourg de 1841
n'était pas situé là où il se trouve
aujourd'hui il remplaça le petit sable
actuel Salazie Salazie étant alors le
village qu'on a actuellement el bourg ce
n'est qu'un an plus tard que l'arrêté du
24 mars fixa el-bourg et Salazie là où
il se trouve désormais pas simple le
cirque refuge des esclaves marron connu
des 1830 une croissance démographique
importante liée à l'installation dans
les hauts des francréoles ainsi 36
familles sivirent accorder des
concessions et y créèrent leur village
utopique en 1843 l'exploitation des
sources thermales lancèrent les sort
d'elbour une fois la route carrossable
construite elle contribuèrent largement
au confort des riches au long jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle la station déclina
ensuite à partir de 1920 la précieuse
eau s'est Atari les touristes replièrent
sur Cilaos mais elle BOURD délaissée a
ainsi gardé son charme d'antan